редакция минфина Тоже имеет свой
небольшой инвестиционный проект мы 3.000
долларов Разместили на счету брокера и в
течение года покупали различные активы
старались диверсифицировать в результате
на данный момент доходность портфеля
чуть выше 4%. то есть мы проигрываем
индекс s&p где-то в пять раз Вы
посмотрели посмотрели наш портфель его
доходность по вашему мнению в чем была
наша ошибка или нет ошибки Нам сейчас
нужно ждать пока эти предприятия
выстрелят
буквально минут 2 посмотрел на портфеле
все что то что мне в глаза бросилось
абсолютно непонятен принцип локации
активов то есть в чём идея за портфелем
это консервативный портфель дивидендный
портфель или агрессивный портфель
ключевого принципа
Почему Потому что когда вы есть портфеля
Идея то там к идее привязывается тайминг
динамик То есть в какой портфель когда
заходить как формировать Как выходить
нет идеи в портфеле раз во вторых я
заметил такую вещь что
только в одном случае Вы действовали по
принципу усилия сильная когда взяли BP
акции BP начали расти Вы сделали
докупили по идее Вы должны были докупать
каждую позицию которая растет обычно
ошибка большинства 90
57-8 процентов инвесторов заключается в
том что они усредняются вниз когда акция
падает они докупают думают теперь
дешевле и средняя цена у них будет ниже
и потом легче будет отыграть И так
бывает Они усредняются до дна на самом
деле усредняться надо вверх то есть
акции которые растут надо и докупать я
это по-другому называю усилия сильная
или там детей везет туда и вкладывать
деньги Поэтому в одном случае только в
акции BP вы докупили это было правильное
движение в остальных вы не докупали
которые падают вы не сокращали которые
растут вы не наращивали а там нужно было
потому что
Есть два вида портфелей неподвижно
портфель неподвижный портфель хорош для
таких инвесторов как у румбард
разместился но для этого нужно на входе
очень тщательно подбирать компании а в
вашем случае нужна динамическая локация
то есть разместились во-первых нужно
разделять локацию не за один раз
заходить в портфель поэтапно в идеале
вот у вас 3000 долларов надо зайти на
1000 долларов потом те которые растут
туда да вкладываете те которые падают
оттуда выходит и динамическая локация
это второй момент третий момент очень
большой очень большая ошибка всех
инвесторов Дело в том что мы все
оперируем в поле познаваемого мы считаем
Мы боимся хаоса Поэтому мы всегда хотим
принимать решения рациональные
основанные на определенной логике
причине причины и следствий
соответственно
Чем ниже уровень людей
тем меньше они на самом деле знают и
попадают в эффект
даннинго Крюгера когда они думают что
они знают много и у них больше
уверенности хоть знаний меньше Но
уверенности больше соответственно Когда
вы выбрали портфель и проинвестировали
вы сходились своего рационального
понимания что вы понимаете что делаете
на самом деле вы не понимали что вы
делаете А раз Вы не понимаете что вы
делаете тогда надо подходить к этому
портфелю как глупому портфелю глупый
портфель в отличие от умного портфеля в
умном портфеле вы как бы выстраиваете
какую-то причинно-следственную связь
логику гипотезу и инвестируйте и
абсолютно это не значит что это будет
сильнее и вы окажетесь правы Если
исходить из логики то будущее всегда
наступает не в том виде в котором мы
ожидаем и никто не может предсказать
будущее то вам надо бы просто брать из
слепо покупать любые компании которые
быстро растут просто
принцип один быстро растет покупают
неважно уровень долго не важно
там с какой стороны Неважно какая у нее
прибыль если прибыль вообще и так далее
А как в этом случае не попасть на
перегреты компании
а перегретая же внутренняя ваша оценка
кажется вот буквально там
два-три месяца назад теста считалось
супер перегретой
херс заключил контракт
[музыка]
сколько-то там 100 тысяч
а капитализация тестов выросла на 105
млрд то есть на каждый автомобиль там на
миллион долларов
это скакнула же скакнула это понимаете
вы считаете что каждый раз что рынком
перекрытым когда вот вывод Здесь вы
считаете рынок перегретой когда он
вырастает вы понимаете что это был
вообще оказывается здесь перегретой у
вас всегда запасные понятия и ощущения
перегретости всегда запаздывает Каждый
раз когда вы считаете что или при
падении особенно когда вы считаете что
достигли дно очень скоро выясняется что
есть еще куда падает и далеко также И
когда происходит бум на рынке поэтому
перегретый рынок ни один человек в этом
мире не может вам сказать перегретой
Никто это никто не знает в принципе
частного инвесторами долларов Можно
заходить на фондовый рынок или это
слишком маленькая сумма чтобы
сформировалась
надо 90 процентов держать в
консервативных активах а 10 процентов
глупые портфель
всё вот это понятно 90 процентов в
депозитах государственных цен на бумагах
и так далее с определенной понятной
доходностью Там пять процентов все
проинвестировал 10 процентов
проинвестировал в глупый портфель
который просто по принципу что растет и
покупаешь Независимо это потолок не
потолок перегрета не перегретый и в
результате благодаря этому вы в целом
понимаете целую доходность по портфелю
Потому что на 10 процентов Вы можете
утроить учитывать капитал Ну это плюс
20-30 процентов прироста вы берете 20 30
процентов прироста Добавляйте 5 вот 35
процентов Но если потеряете все сто
процентов А это часть лучей из десяти
процентов 100% потеряете то 90 процентов
вашего капитала плюс 5 доходность 95 но
все равно